OBVIOUSLY, I'VE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
FOX NEWS ANALYST HOWARD KURTZ
WITH THE FALLOUT TONIGHT.
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT TRUMP
CLAIMED VINDICATION TODAY IN HIS
LATEST BATTLE WITH THE MEDIA.
FAKE NEWS MEDIA HAD ME CALLING
IMMIGRANTS OR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ANIMALS, WRONG.
THEY WERE BEGRUDGINGLY FORCED TO
WITHDRAW THEIR STORIES.
THE PRESIDENT WAS PUSHING BACK
AGAINST HEADLINES THAT TOOK HIS
WORDS OUT OF CONTEXT.
THE AP HAD TWEETED, TRUMP
REFERRED TO THOSE CROSSING THE
U.S. BORDER ILLEGALLY AS
ANIMALS.
CNN TWEETED THE QUOTE, THESE
AREN'T PEOPLE, THESE ARE
ANIMALS, AS HAVING HAPPENED WHEN
TRUMP CRITICIZED U.S.
IMMIGRATION LAWS.
NOW, AP HAS DELETED THE TWEET.
ONE ANCHOR CLARIFIED THINGS THIS
WAY.
>> WHEN HE APPEARS TO BE VERY
CLEARLY RESPONDING TO A COMMENT
ABOUT MEMBERS OF A VIOLENT GAME.
>> Reporter: HERE'S HOW THE
STORY UNFOLDED.
SPEAK TO YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE
HOW BAD THESE PEOPLE ARE.
THESE AREN'T PEOPLE, THESE ARE
ANIMALS.
>> Reporter: BUT WHAT WAS
DOWNPLAYED OR IGNORED WAS THAT
TRUMP WAS RESPONDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA SHERIFF ON THE
FRUSTRATIONS IN TRACKING THE
MS-13 GANG MEMBERS.
>> THE MS-13 GANG MEMBERS I KNOW
ABOUT, .
>> Reporter: EVEN NOW SOME
JOURNALS AREN'T ACCEPTING HIS
EXPLANATION.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE AS HE WAS
REFERRING TO THE CRIMINAL
IMMIGRANT GANG MS-13, NOT TO ALL
IMMIGRANTS.
BUT HE DIDN'T SAY SO.
>> TRUMP DEFENDERS IMMEDIATELY
CLAIMED THAT THE PRESENT WAS
ONLY TALKING ABOUT THE MEMBERS
OF THE GANG MS-13, WHICH IS NOT
TRUE.
>> I REFUSE TO ALLOW THIS
PRESIDENT TO KIND OF DEFINE GOOD
IMMIGRANT/BAD IMMIGRANT, BECAUSE
THE LITMUS TEST AT THIS POINT
IS, SIMPLY PEOPLE WHO WERE NOT
BORN IN THIS COUNTRY ARE ANIMALS
BORN IN THIS COUNTRY ARE ANIMAL
ANIMALS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS OPEN TO
MISINTERPRETATION WHEN HE USES
SWEEPING INCENDIARY LANGUAGE,
BUT IN THIS CASE, SOME NEWS